how does the graph of a pair of linear
equations look let's take two equations
first X plus y equals 4 and second X
minus y equals 2 in the previous video
we plotted the graph of the first
equation now let's plot the graph of the
second one on the same plane let's see
what we get we make a similar table on
the left for the second equation and get
three pairs of values for x and y we
assume three random values for X and get
appropriate values for y the 3 / 3 pairs
of values we get a negative 1 comma
negative 3 0 comma negative 2 and 1
comma negative 1 plop in these points
and joining them we get another straight
line for the second equation this line
represents the equation X minus y equals
2 and the previous one represents X plus
y equals 4 now look at this graph and
tell me what all can you deduce
let's talk about the things we've
discussed in the previous video the
graphs of linear equations are always
straight lines next every point that
lies on this line would be a solution
for the equation X plus y equals four
and every point that lies on this line
will be a solution for the equation X
minus y equals two for instance
4 comma 2 would be a solution for the
equation X minus y equals 2 4 minus 2 is
2 and what about the points that lie on
neither of the lines easy
they will not be the solutions for
either of them is there anything else
you can see on this graph
anything interesting look at the point
where both lines intersect what can you
tell me about this point yes this point
lies on both the lines and what does
that imply it implies that this point is
the solution to both the equations the
point 3 comma 1 is the solution to both
the equations you can even try it out
mathematically 3 plus 1 is 4 and 3 minus
1 is 2 both equations are satisfied so
clapping graphs of pairs of linear
equations also gives us the solution
this pair of linear equations has
exactly one solution but is why it's
called a consistent pair of linear
equations well any pair of linear
equations always have just one solution
can do have two solutions and they have
no solutions or can they have infinite
solutions all the answers in the next
video
you
[Music]